- Did you cry like a baby?
- [Michael] I fuckin' did, dude.
I took them up there
solo, just fuckin' brutal.
- Fuck, how long did you have the dog?
- [Michael] He was only
nine, but he was a big dog.
- You had him for nine, you had 'em all?
That's tough.
- [Michael] Yeah, it's one of
those shitty fucking things.
But you know, it's part
of being a dog owner, so.
- John, you've put down a dog?
You seemed super sad just now.
- [John] No, just the
way he told that story.
- Yeah, he did a good job.
- Yeah, no,
you fucking got to do it.
- It's like damn, John's got a dog.
There's some deep shit there.
Spot broke his heart when he was 14.
You good Dust, 317?
Hey everybody it's Gary Vaynerchuk,
episode 317 of the Ask Gary Vee Show.
And Dustin wants him to put the.
- [Dustin] Try keeping it close to you.
- Good Dust, way to
interrupt the show, bro.
(laughter)
But I love it, it's great
to have Michael here.
I'm gonna let him introduce
himself in a second.
But for everybody who's
watching on Instagram,
you need to go to Facebook and YouTube
if you want to ask a question.
For everybody on Facebook and YouTube,
the way you ask a question is putting in
your phone number in the comment section
with some thematics of what you're
kind of gonna go with the question.
And to establish thematics,
Michael why don't you tell
everybody who you are,
what you do, and then I'll
jump in, ask some questions,
and we'll jam and try to bring some value.
- Sweet.
My name is Michael Chernow, I
am a restaurant entrepreneur.
Been at it for a long time,
born and raised in
Manhattan, New York City.
- [Gary] Born and raised?
- Born and raised.
- [Gary] Where'd you live?
- 87th and First as a kid.
- Love it.
Right by a baseball card
store up there, Alex's--
- [Michael] Alex's MVP!
- Let's go baby!
- My dog!
- Let's go.
You bought cards there?
Love it.
- Yeah I bought cards there.
There's very few people
that know about Alex's MVP.
- I'm sneaky.
- That's so fuckin' cool.
So I grew up up there.
You know growing up in New York
in Manhatten sort of like--
- How old are you?
- [Michael] 38.
- [Gary] Okay, keep going,
just wanted to get the
context of what timing.
- You know, really growing up in the '90s?
I was born in '80,
but like I was coming
into my own in the '90s.
- [Gary] You were 10 in 1990.
- I was 10, but I was
still, dude, I was in it.
New York, you get exposed much younger,
you get exposed much younger.
- Quick.
How young were you when you walked
the street of New York by your full self?
Like to school,
truly by yourself of length
that is actually like.
I remember when I walked to school
in sixth grade and it was far,
I was like, now I'm grown.
- So my parents, you know I
love my fuckin' parents, but.
- Of course.
By the way I love my fucking parents, but,
might be one of the great T-shirts,
can we make that T-shirt actually?
Yo team, you got this Johnny?
I want to make a T-shirt,
I love my fucking parents,
and then I want the but to be big.
- [Michael] I better get a
fuckin' quote on that shit.
- You might get a little something.
(Michael laughs)
Go ahead.
You love your fuckin' parents, but?
- So my element, I went to PS 158,
elementary school on 76th
Street and New York Ave.
Big public school.
And I was on the bus from
86th Street to 79th Street
when I was like straight
up in third fourth grade,
my sister and I.
And so I was going to school pretty young,
and then I probably started
stepping on the train
when I was like fifth sixth grade.
And I remember very clearly
specifically around this time,
July 4th, going down to Canal Street
as like a young buck kid,
12 years old, to get fireworks.
And like walking down like back alleys,
you know the Chinese guys
get you on the street,
and then they walk you into
the back alley to the Italian guys,
and that's where like the
fuckin' blockbusters are,
you know like the dynamite is?
And I remember being, it's just ill.
Like as a kid you just grow
up in the city, you know?
- Quick.
- Quick, quick.
- You're like equal 12 year
old cousins are in Jersey
or like Long Island or Connecticut.
- And they're like
fuckin' just stepping on
a skateboard for the first time.
- Yeah, exactly, with like a helmet on.
- [Michael] And they all were
in Long Island, actually.
But anyway, so I got my first, you know,
I fuckin' take in your content,
I fuckin' love your content.
- Thank you man.
- And I love it because it's
fuckin' real and it speaks to me.
And I've like came out of the womb sort of
with this hustler mentality.
I was selling my fuckin' toys
as early as I can remember.
- Were you a good student?
- [Michael] No.
- Terrible?
- I wasn't terrible.
I was probably like a 75 to 80 student,
you know what I mean?
I was like a B.
- Pretty good.
So it came easy to you.
- It came easy to me.
I hated fuckin' homework,
I was not a study guy.
And you know I went to
college for six months
and fuckin' just I thought this was
the biggest waste of time honestly.
And that's not for everybody, by the way.
But like for it was like I went here--
- You went because first
of all your age group,
there weren't that many
viable alternatives back then.
Second of all for your parents, or no?
- Let me preface this a little bit.
So I grew up, my household was pretty,
it wasn't the best upbringing, right?
I had a tough relationship with my father,
even though I love him, and he's gone now.
But you know I had a tough
relationship, it was tough.
- [Gary] They were together?
- They were together.
- [Gary] But he made it tough.
- He made it tough.
And it wasn't that he was strict,
he was just a straight up asshole,
like that's the bottom line.
He was a straight up asshole.
But he taught me three incredible things
that I'd love to mention at some point.
- [Gary] Please, mention them now.
- Okay so the three things
that my pops taught me were
really important and could potentially
be controversial right now,
so like, and I never
would have thought of this
ever until somebody brought it up to me.
But my father taught me that when
I was probably there or four years old
we were walking into an elevator.
I remember it like I was yesterday.
- [Gary] Jesus, three or four.
Go ahead.
- Walking into an elevator and my father
grabbed me by the back of my neck,
pulled me out, looked at me,
put his hands on my shoulders,
looked at me and said,
"You never ever walk in
front of a woman, ever."
- [Gary] I like it.
- And like that shit just stuck with me.
And it stuck with me to this very day,
he scared the daylights
out of me at that age.
And so like I, and I've passed
it on to my sons, right?
- And listen to your point,
listen, the world evolves.
Political correctness, properness,
evolution, it's all great.
But I think look we cast so
much judgment on each other.
What a lot of people,
when they're over cynical,
to your point, not thinking
that that could be a bad thing.
You know I have a friend
who also got mad at me
around opening the door.
Something went down and the conversation
that I had with her was like,
look, mazel tov, I respect your opinion.
You also have to think about
how that trickles down.
Like you're worried about the semantic.
What about the macro treating respect
and things of that nature?
So you know to your point, so okay.
So he scared the fuck out
of you when you were four.
- And that shit has stuck
with me to this very day.
My wife hates it.
Like I'll be standing at
like Bloomingdales and like
holding a fucking door.
- For an hour.
Dude I do the same shit.
You've seen me do it
in an elevator, right?
Like sometimes it takes
like an extra minute
'cause I'm like and you, and you.
Right, you've noticed it?
- [Michael] And honestly
it's not just women for me.
- Me too.
- I just fuckin' do that.
- I do that for non-athletic
dudes like John, you know?
(laughter)
Go ahead, I just wanted to
harass him for no reason.
Poor guy's just sitting there filming
Instagram just having a good day.
Go ahead.
- And he taught me when I give a handshake
to squeeze and look in someone's eyes.
- He was an old school
dude, old school dude.
Was his pops tough on him?
- His pops was an animal.
And his pops, my grandfather,
still alive, 97, kicking.
- And was he awesome to you?
Was it one of those clashes
there, or animal to you to?
- Not animal in the way he
was an animal to my dad.
- That's what I mean,
that's what the cliche story is, right?
Like tough as fuck on the dad,
but like went through the process
and played the grandson different.
And then there's just animal to animal,
there's all sorts of
versions, I was just curious.
- Yeah no, I mean he's
done some ill shit to me,
my grandfather.
- [Gary] Like unacceptable?
- Like just fuckin' you know
took me in a room when I was,
I was a bad kid.
Like I was a bad kid, hands down.
- Like stealing, fighting,
all sorts of shit?
Way worse?
(laughter)
Your reaction is all I need.
- I was just like, I was a bad kid.
I moved out of my parents' house.
Anyway, speeding up,
I moved out of my parents'
house when I was 15,
and I was sort of like on the street,
you know bouncing around,
just getting after--
- [Gary] Drug dealing?
- Just getting after the hustle.
- Whatever took.
- I had a number of side hustles.
So my first job was at 13 delivering
fucking couch potato videos.
Then I got a job, on
Rollerblades by the way,
which is fucking insane.
Then I got a job at a restaurant.
- [Gary] That crushed it
with the ladies, right?
(Gary laughs)
- Especially in '93.
No but, you know,
I got a job right down the street
delivering food at a restaurant.
And that's when I was like,
wow, I love this environment.
I loved the noise, I loved
just like the action.
I need the action.
- Bro, do you know that I literally
play music top loud speed?
You know how much noise
I need at all times?
You guys know like sometimes
when it's too quiet here,
noise is the only thing
I'm comfortable in.
I'm gonna tell you something crazy.
I'm having a problem because
New York City is starting to feel slow.
(Michael laughs)
And I'm like,
if'that's true I'm gonna end
up in some weird town in Asia.
- [Michael] Yeah that's
the only other place
that I can think of that
could be any faster.
- I'm like, fuck, I'm gonna
have to move to China.
- Yeah you might have to move to
like the center crosswalk in Japan.
You know like that one that
you see all the fucking,
you'd have to live there.
- I'll just live there,
I'm like hustling, pick
a ball, pick a ball!
(laughing) People are like,
what happened to Gary?
- But so I got a job,
and that's when I knew
that like I can get money.
I can just get money and I
always kind of thought that way,
I had a dog walking fucking business
before I got my first real job.
And then one thing led
to the next and I got
hooked up with this night club situation
where they were like handing out fliers,
and back in the day there
was no email, right?
So like it was like handing out fliers,
promoting in front of the club.
So I connected with all these promoters.
- And that was a skill, listen.
Sending out emails versus handing out
fliers in real life to people,
you're talking about two
very different skillsets.
- Well they also thought
it was really funny to have
a 15 year old kid on a skateboard
outside of the nightclub.
- At 15 I looked nine.
What did you look like at 15?
- I looked really young too.
- Like 13?
- Probably.
- But like an 18 year old attitude?
- Well, yeah, for sure.
I was always the youngest and
I was like good in the room.
I could sit in a room and I
could sit with anybody really,
and I don't know where that came from.
- And what about dealting
with girls and guys?
Did you like crush with both,
were you like better at that
point with guys than girls,
better with girls than guys?
That's always an
interesting questions to me,
that's a semantic of that
charisma that I'm always,
isn't that an interesting question?
'Cause there's version of,
you know where I'm going with this.
There's some people that do
better than one with the other,
or the reverse.
- You know it is an interesting question,
and I actually never fucking
thought of that question.
- You know what's funny about it?
I've never asked it.
But I've been thinking
about it for the last year,
and I'm super pumped I just delivered it,
and I'm pumped with the
way you responded to it,
and now I'm pumped to keep
going down the rabbit hole
of what does it actually mean.
So anyway, answer it.
At that point?
- I will say this.
I was in high school young,
'cause my birthday is
at the end of the year.
- [Gary] When's your birthday?
- October, October 21st.
- [Gary] Mine's November
14th, but go ahead.
October is tricky, right?
Because the November people
were older, actually.
- Oh yeah maybe that's right,
'cause that was the cutoff.
So I was always the youngest in my class.
And I remember so clearly
in my freshman year
of high school I was 13 and
like really for the first time
some chick took me aside
and was like, you're hot.
And I was like, oh?
I was like, whoop, wait a second!
There's a whole 'nother world!
- Alex's baseball cards is not
necessarily as important to me.
- [Michael] Grab bag Marvel cards?
- Not as interesting.
That like lit you up mentally?
- It just made me
realize that like, wait--
- [Gary] Things were about to happen.
- Totally, there's like a
whole 'nother element to life.
(Gary laughs)
So anyway, so I had this hustle
with the handing out fliers.
And then I linked up with the promoters,
and they all needed all
their envelopes stuffed.
And there was like 10 of them.
And I started like sort of
hanging out inside this club,
stuffing these envelopes,
and then I got all my friends
to stuff the envelopes.
And so now I had this like
ring of envelope stuffing,
promoting, things going on.
And then I started working in the club.
- We might also have to start an
envelope staffing mafia T-shirt.
(Michael laughs)
I just wanna make a bunch
of T-shirts from this episode.
Keep going.
- But you know it taught me a lot.
And for whatever reason I just
always had these weird
little side hustles.
But all through high school and
I don't know how I fuckin' did it,
but I didn't live at home.
I like lived in other people's houses.
But I stayed in high school
and I graduated high school.
Which is crazy.
- So high school friends'
parents' took you in in
theory for periods of times?
- No because remember I
was always the youngest,
so I hung out with older kids that like
had apartments or had NYU dorms.
- Got it.
So the way cooler version of
where I was going with it.
Like it's one thing to
be like the second son
in a house that's like a nice family.
It's way different to be
staying in college dorms
or people that are 18
with their own apartment.
- When I moved out of my parents' house--
- That's when you grow up fuckin' fast.
- Dude, fast.
I moved out and I moved right into
Alumni Hall NYU dorm on 9th and 3rd.
Literally 15, I knew this
girl who I used to party,
and I was like, yo, I'm moving in.
And she was like, bet, let's do it.
And so I moved in there.
- And she definitely didn't say bet,
because that's new terminology.
She said radical. (laughs)
Go ahead.
- So anyways so I did that,
then I lived in some crazy
loft on Horacio Street.
I just ended up in crazy places.
- D'you think you should make a movie?
- I don't know if I should make a movie,
but I definitely will
write a book at some point.
- I think one day you
should produce a movie
that's softly based on your life, right?
'Cause you need to embellish
it for the silver screen,
change some shit,
that kind of has like a
Basketball Diaries vibe.
- I love that movie.
- Me too.
- That movie fucked me up, dude.
- That one girl in that
movie changed my life.
That's when I think I
became a man. (laughs)
I was like, who is that with Leo?
- Anyway, but there is
a light at the end of
the tunnel obviously in this story,
and the experience and
the stories that I have
from growing up in New
York City and just--
- Why did that movie fuck you up?
It was like the coolest
movie that had ever come out.
- Well it fucked me up because
I like ended up struggling with drugs.
- Of course you had it
somewhat under control.
Drugs is a very simple game.
Where were you in that process
when that movie came up?
In the struggling part, on the
verge of the struggling part?
Or trying to get out
of the struggling part?
- That movie came out in
like '90 what, '98, '99?
- [Gary] Yeah, that feels right.
- So like when I was I
really knew that I was like,
holy shit dude you've
turned into this animal.
Like you've turned into this
guy that's like, you know.
- The guy you promised
yourself you would never be,
that you would stop just short of.
- [Michael] I actually
never promised myself
that I would never be that
guy, because my surroundings.
- You actually strived
to be that guy. (laughs)
- 'Cause at the end of the day though,
I always had a job, I
never did not have a job.
I always had a job in a restaurant.
- [Gary] 'Cause you loved it,
that makes sense.
- 'Cause I loved it.
- Yeah that's where people get caught.
Because if they're lucky
enough to love that,
it's the thing they use to
justify that they're good.
- Pretty much.
And also it was like a have
my cake and eat it too situation.
I worked in restaurants, you know?
Restaurants and night clubs.
So I was like able to live the
life that I actually enjoyed
which was fuckin' goin' hard and then also
like develop my Rolodex with
growing a network of people.
Anyway, and I love people man.
I believe people are
everything, period and done.
- That's probably something
that when you started consuming
or seeing some of my stuff like
we connected on that, right?
'Cause a lot of people
don't talk about that.
I talk it about it heavy.
- It is everything, and in my opinion,
and now I've opened 18
restaurants in my career,
and like I look at it and I say,
if you run a business strictly on a PNL
it's fuckin' big ol' trouble.
- It's game over.
- If you're not playing offense--
- You ready for this?
I barely run on a PNL.
- [Michael] I know that
listening to you, I know that.
- Like I am so not interested.
I only care about one thing,
Will I make payroll?
My interest and my PNL stops and
starts with can I pay my bills?
- Yeah, I mean look.
And it's probably because I
was a technician for years
before I opened my first business, right?
I got my first job in a
restaurant either 12 or 13,
I don't fuckin' remember.
But you know I didn't open my
first restaurant until I was 28.
- What was the restaurant that you
opened for whom right before that?
What was the last stop prior to your own?
- So it was eight years I spent
in one spot in the east village.
And this guy was, it still
is one of the best places.
- [Gary] Which is?
- Frank Restaurant, second half.
And the beauty of that, I learned so much.
- 20 to 28?
- 20 to 28.
And I learned so much in that restaurant.
I learned how to like talk about like
getting out there and like first of all--
- Getting a PHD in real life?
- In real life because there
was really no management,
so I was really able to
like manage my own shit.
And also I was able to--
- This is the thing I love about like
a lot of these guys and
gals that work on my team.
Like the cliche thing that
everybody looks at is like,
we need more structure.
I'm like, that's cool.
I'm like, one day you will be on a podcast
talking about how awesome
it was of being able to
actually do shit with less structure.
- I mean look Frank I fuckin' love you bro
and if you're listenin' to this
shit, you know what I mean?
There was no structure and like I
had to be the guy to do it.
And the other beauty of that place--
- That is the structure.
I hope Frank's right now watching this,
and he's like, "That's the
structure, mother fucker."
Like that's the structure!
It's a different structure.
It's the gray to the black and white.
- Pretty much, that's it, I love that.
You fuckin' hear that shit?
(Gary laughs)
- [Michaal And Gary] T-shirt!
- So you learned a fuck load there?
- I learned a fuck ton there and
I also like really honed
my salesmanship there.
- Hey John, I apologize.
Troudy, with empathy you
can't believe how much shit
in the first year or so
that you took for granted
'cause I was doing that part that
you were like what the fuck, right?
Meaning like now that you're
at the top of a business,
all the shit that every
time you were an employee,
even if you were a chief of staff to me,
even as close as you got to the sun,
now that you're on the other side of it,
you're like, what the fuck?
Right?
- [John] Yeah, it's real.
- That's what creating a lack of structure
gets you to right on the
edge and then you learn
the next part you needed in the
first 24 months up to your 30th birthday.
Tasting the new environment
of your own shit.
- I also you know, I like
became a man in that restaurant,
you know what I mean?
Not only I became a man like an evolution,
but like I got, you know,
I'm not ashamed to say.
I'm sober 15 years, I'm
sober a long fuckin' time,
you know what I mean?
And because of Frank, really,
Frank fuckin' set me up.
- How?
Punched you in the face?
- [Michael] Punched me in the face.
- The only way.
- Punched me in the face.
- And had the juice to do it.
- Well he basically was
like, you're fired bro.
Like I love you, he's
like I fuckin' love you,
and you're the best
bartender I've ever had.
And like I've never seen anybody
fuckin' sell Quintarelli like you.
But like, you're gone.
- That's a very expensive Amarone,
for everybody who's under educated.
But you're gone.
- Yeah he was like, you're gone.
- And I was like, Frank,
you can't do that to me.
Because my job was
everything, it was just it.
- Troudy, you're fired.
(Michael laughs)
Keep going.
- But like that was it,
and so he basically,
I pretty much got on my
fuckin' hands and knees,
and I was like, Frank man,
this is what keeps me whole.
- [Gary] And where did he go with it?
- And he was like you gotta
show up to the restaurant
every morning at 8 o'clock and clean
with the porters and call me,
and if you call me a minute past eight
you're fuckin' gone and
you gotta get sober.
- So he went with the yes,
because you know I've seen both work.
He went with the yes, made it
painful, and created a rule.
Said yes, made it painful,
and created a singular rule.
- And by the way I just want
to say something about that.
I don't think that that,
I know from my experience now like
you cannot make anybody do shit.
- Couldn't agree more.
- You just can't.
You can beat the shit out of somebody
like literally to a pulp and be like,
you have to do this or I'm
gonna continue beating you.
And if internally soulfully
they're not interested in doing it,
it's a wrap, there's no shot, it's a wrap.
And I don't know much, right?
But I do know that.
- You know what's also awesome is
you were tired at that point.
Like that's the answer
to that question too.
The only time people make
that flip in anything,
forget about even addiction,
even like career changes,
even relationship, it's
just when you're, that's it.
You're just tired.
You know what I mean?
- I was done, I was done.
I just needed that one last whap.
- You were at that 23 year
old version of yourself.
The 20 year old version
of yourself wasn't done.
The flame was hot.
You would've been like, fuck you Frank,
I'm gonna build a restaurant
across the street and kill you.
That's just what it is.
- But like the beauty of
it all was I was able to
really stay like you know
through that time moving out,
like I just had this passion
this drive to do shit
and not be a deadbeat and not be a bum.
And I got my shit together,
and then I you know I went to
culinary school, I did that.
And that was actually, I said,
"Hey Frank," after I was
sober for a year I was like,
"Dude, I'm gonna go out there and do this.
"I'm not saying I'm gonna do it right now,
"but I'm gonna go out and do it."
Whatever it was, I was like,
one day I'm gonna do it.
And he was like, and I don't
know what he would say now.
Or how he felt then.
But he basically was like, I
dunno if you got it in you.
- [Gary] I love it.
That was the best fuckin'
thing he could say to you.
- That was the best thing he said to me,
because I just went out
and fuckin' murdered.
- Do you know that I manifest
people doing that to me?
That the one thing in my
life that all this stuff
that's going on with me that
is heartbreaking is that
now people think I can do things?
And I'm like literally
probably gonna go to Japan
and sit in that corner
because like literally,
like this sneaker deal was 100% that.
I'm like okay this is something nobody
thinks I'm gonna be able to pull off.
They're gonna think I'm stretching here.
I'm reachin'.
Like somebody telling
me I can't is my oxygen.
- Me too, bro, me too.
And honestly you know I
sometimes I wish it wasn't,
you know what I mean?
- There's a second part to it.
When I fail after Caleb told
me that I can't make films
I actually don't judge myself.
And that's where you're
fuckin' unstoppable.
If you're completely
driven by that you can't
and then you actually win both ways
because when you win you're
like told you motherfucker,
or when you lose you're like
yeah, I can't hear your booing.
Well then you're fuckin' unstoppable.
You understand?
That's an interesting nuance to it.
- You know I was sitting down with a
good friend of mine a couple of weeks ago,
and this dude, he's an amazing dude.
I mean he's a complete
lunatic, and he knows it.
But he said some shit
to me that I was like,
wow, that might have been the most sort of
righteous thing I've ever heard you say.
And he was like, "Mike
the answer to happiness
"or the key to happiness is
accepting the moment, done."
And he was like that doesn't mean
you're gonna be fuckin'
happy all the time.
But it means if you can actually accept
the moment and not fight the moment,
like try to control when
shit's not going your way
and actually accept it, receive
it, and fuckin' respond?
Like that is happiness,
because you're not gonna
be constantly in a battle
with yourself and everything around you,
because you have zero fuckin' control.
- You know where my head goes on that?
Which is a funny build.
So I hear that and I'm like,
that's absolutely right.
And then I was like, fuck man.
And for me?
Honestly, I'm serious shit bro.
I'm even the other,
like I can't even tell you how
much I like when shit's bad.
- But that's it though!
- Bro I actually think
I like losing more than winning.
- [Gary] I know, and I've
heard you say that before.
- And I'm like, I'm working
through my own shit here.
I'm like this is fucking crazy.
I hate the Yankees and the Rangers now
'cause they won me a championship
and I've got nothin'
but fucking dead passion
for the Nix and Jets 'cause I haven't.
Like all the people,
the reason I make fun of all
those Steph Curry fuckin'
Jersey kids is they need
affirmation from a third party.
They jump on bandwagons.
I'm jumpin' off bandwagons.
I didn't even get to
enjoy the Yankee dynasty
after eating shit in the
'80s and the early '90s
because after fucking Charley
Hayes caught the ball,
I have not watched a complete
Yankee game since 1996!
I don't even know what Jeter did.
- [Michael] 'Cause you were
just fuckin' head down.
- 'Cause I checked out.
Because I like losing more than winning.
How do you beat somebody like that?
You don't.
I believe that.
And I don't say that as like--
- [Michael] Can I just
say something about?
- Yeah, you can do anything.
- That in itself right
there, what you just said,
is in an essence accepting the shit.
- [Gary] I believe that.
- It's not like you're
like going into the ring
and you're like I'm gonna lose.
You're like, I'm gonna go into the ring,
I'm gonna fucking put it on someone,
and if I lose it's all good.
- Not only is it all good,
and this is where it
gets real interesting.
Hat tip to that fuckin' guy.
Like he beat me.
I'm pissed.
I remember when I was
doing great with investing
and like people were starting
to really floss on me,
and I was like, what about Chris Sta-ka?
What about Scott Belsky?
They did it better.
During the same era.
We all started in the general same place,
so like I just like the merit of the game.
- The journey.
- I hate watching
people in the restaurant business shit on
the guy or gal that's
beating them currently.
I'm like what the fuck are
you spending all your time
shitting on somebody who's out executing?
- [Michael] Like who does that?
- Everybody.
- [Michael] In the restaurant world?
- In every world.
In every world where people compete,
whoever's currently winning is getting
whispered behind because people do that.
- You know what's weird?
And maybe I'm just fuckin'
oblivious to this shit.
I believe in the restaurant world--
- [Gary] You're oblivious.
(laughs)
I'm not even gonna let
you finish the sentence.
Go ahead.
- Listen listen listen.
Maybe at my level like
the super high level guys,
like the guys that are doing like
60 million in revenue out of a restaurant,
maybe they're like I'm gonna put a dagger
through my fuckin' cotenants heart.
- They're not saying that.
Whoever's in a white heat moment.
Shake Shack.
- There's haters.
Oh, there's haters.
- By the way, that's not
actually where I'm going.
Yes.
I'm actually talking about
just competitive banter.
Like it's not even bad.
What, you don't think KD has
said something about Harden?
You don't think Westbrook has some
words about Paul George's game?
It's the game.
And I'm just always curious about that.
- You know like I mean look dude,
I'm an overly fuckin' optimistic guy.
I'm the guy, truly,
'cause I just know that the business
to business relationships for me,
like I know my whole shit
is built on relationships.
Everything.
It's built on me being--
- Actually you know what
we've like so enjoying this,
we're actually hanging out
more than what I normally do.
(Michael laughs)
For two minutes,
please tell everybody what
your business currently is.
(laughter)
- So anyway, so I
finished culinary school,
I started to think about
what I was gonna do.
And I wrote a business plan with
my best friend from childhood.
- Remember business plans?
None of these fuckers think
about that shit anymore.
- Shit is real.
Now they're called decks,
let's just be real.
I started writing a business plan.
My boy from childhood who actually
got me my first restaurant job,
Dan Holzman, amazing dude.
We partnered up,
we came up with this idea
for the meatball shop,
and 14 regulars from
Frank wrote me a check.
- That makes sense.
Like I'm mad that I wasn't going there,
'cause that would've
been a good investment.
'Cause some of that
shit, like hearing that,
that was the easiest check
those 14 people wrote.
- And they all fuckin'
did very well. (laughs)
- Yes they did.
And when I think about
where I've done well,
it is that story.
Not when it made sense,
when you had context for the
EQ and the drive of the human.
The amount of good
investments I'm about to make
over the next 20 years is
going to be staggering,
'cause shit is getting clear.
- And do you make your investments
strictly based on the fuckin' person?
- I'm about to.
That's why the sentence that just
came out of my mouth came out.
Because when I did it was called Facebook,
Twitter and Tumblr, and when
I thought it was hot shit,
I started thinking I was a
VC, they weren't as good.
So now I'm going back
to who the fuck I am.
- [Michael] I love that.
- And even more interesting,
it's why I've eaten shit and
build an agency for 10 years.
I'm not gonna do that, I'm
gonna home grown all my shit.
- Culture is fucking everything,
and you know and that's
why quite frankly--
- So 14 regulars write a check.
Where did you guys open your first place?
- Opened up a restaurant on Stanton Street
in the lower east side.
- [Gary] When?
- February 10th, 2010.
February 9th, 2010.
So we're nine and a half years old.
- So right after the world melted.
- Right after, like the
pit, like the fuckin' pit.
- Which means you were
already in motion, no?
- Well the beauty of the brand, yes, 100%.
- I know where you're
gonna go with the brand,
before we get to that, you're
about to start a sentence--
- [Michael] I was in motion
in the world was crashing.
- When Lehman's fell, like the
next day were you like what,
didn't even know?
- Didn't even fuckin',
didn't even scratch my,
I didn't even have a fucking computer.
Like I had like a desktop,
you know what I mean?
Like I didn't email, you
know what I'm saying?
I was all EQ, like that was it, period.
I was that guy.
- I get it, I get it.
You'd like shit on phones?
You'd be like if I can't
shake the man's hand, fuck it?
(laughs)
- But I was just not that guy.
And then that shit went
down and like you know,
I wrote the plan and
remember when Daniel and I
were talking about it and we were like
man we gotta make this
shit recession proof.
Like we gotta make it so valuable,
like it's gotta have such value that like
people are gonna come no matter what.
People gotta eat, right?
So if you can sell something and offer
an environment and an atmosphere
that people can get down with like
play Biggie Smalls and fuckin'
serve bowls of meatballs
for five dollars with a smile,
like who's not gonna want
to get down with that?
- These dudes are like,
wait a minute, I'm going.
- No they're like, they've all been,
you know what I'm saying?
- [Gary] That's right.
How many locations?
- There's eight now.
So there's eight, six in the city,
one in DC, one in Connecticut,
we just opened up in Connecticut.
- And how are you thinking about
the expansion of that brand?
- I think the expansion of that
brand is gonna grow concentrically,
probably suburban markets.
It's become you know I launched
that brand in the sort of,
the people that I launched
that brand with are now,
you know, wife'd up with kids,
you know what I'm saying?
Like that's the truth, right?
And they all live in like West Port,
Connecticut, or something like that,
and that's why I opened up
in West Port, Connecticut.
So like we're gonna grow
that brand that way.
- You're gonna follow them,
all the way to retirement
homes in Florida.
- [Michael] But when you think about it,
you know what I mean--
- Yeah, I believe in that shit.
- So I built out that restaurant concept,
and then four and half, five years in,
I learned, this was an
invaluable lesson for me.
I am really good at creating
brand building culture,
developing teams.
And just sort of harnessing that.
When it comes to day to day ops
and like all the logistics?
Not my thing.
It's not that it's not my
thing, I'm just not good at it.
- Got it.
I was just about to ask you and
you beat me to the punch line.
'Cause in that world
it's super interesting,
some people are more
capable at it and hate it.
Some people like it, just
aren't capable at it.
So you just felt like--
- I'm not good at it.
I did it 'cause I had to, I had to.
- Not a good use of your time.
- For me you want me as the front man.
Like that's what you want me to be.
- You need to be the sizzle.
- And the teams, like the people?
- [Gary] They need to be the steak.
- What I've learned is
that in order to move,
like make waves, I opened a
restaurant in New York City
where there's 24,000 restaurants,
1,000 restaurants open and
close every fuckin' day.
In order to make a wave you have to have
a group of people that are
waving the flag, period.
Like you just need to do that.
And they need to wave the flag,
and the only way to do
that is through culture.
And the only way to do
that is through optimism
and listening and empathy and like being
all the shit that you fucking preach?
That is absolutely necessary
in my opinion in today's world.
And you can say, you know,
people aren't selling
restaurant businesses
necessarily right now for
seven billion dollars.
- [Gary] Who gives a fuck?
- But like if you can do some great shit,
that is the way to do it in my opinion.
- Did you observe me looking for power
and made that happen?
- Yep.
- That is one of the
more impressive things
that have happened on
my team in a long time.
- Thank you.
- You're welcome Si-non.
- So anyways, I learned my role,
I needed to know my role,
and my role was in that,
and as the business grew it became
much more of an operational business
and a logistical business.
- [Gary] I totally understand.
- That was my turn, my time,
to pass the baton and be like,
guys, I'm fuckin' in this,
I'm the biggest cheerleader,
but I'm gonna zoom out and step back
and create some new shit because
that's what keeps me going.
And so I did, I made that call,
Daniel took on the CEO role, I zoomed out.
And still a partner,
still fuckin' hoo-rah guy.
But I launched a new
business called Seymour's,
there's now six of those in
the city about four years ago.
And you know that's how I
think I'm gonna go about it.
- What's the biggest thing you've learned
that you were wrong about
in launching Seymour's?
'Cause that transition,
what you just went through,
I love, and like,
I know how on fire you
were at that moment,
because much like you were ready at 23,
you were ready when
you launched Seymour's.
You'd known you weren't the
operations guy for a while,
so you know you hold that in.
Now you're zooming out and boy
did you love that zoom out phase,
because you're doing
the appropriate thing,
everything's going right.
Now you got this new baby
that you're about to go,
that you're fuckin' pumped.
The confidence level is uncomfortable,
'cause you have success,
you're more primed,
you have more experience.
And then inevitably like any business,
there's certain things that didn't go
the way you thought they
were gonna go on that.
Here we are how many years later?
- Four.
- So perfect, a great
time to ask this question.
What were you wrong about?
- So it's a tough one, right?
- [Gary] Because you're currently in it.
- I'm fuckin' wrong about a lot of shit,
but I like go for it, right?
And I like to do a lot
of different things.
- You're also in it, you know?
So it'll be a lot easier to answer
this question in seven years.
Right now--
- Well no, I know what I did
wrong, I know what I did wrong.
And I didn't do it wrong in the beginning.
- [Gary] Keep going.
- I launched Seymour's partner free.
I raised money, but I had no partners.
I had a team of amazing fucking people
that believed in the
fucking mission, right?
They believed in me, they
believed in the mission,
and we went.
- And what was the mission?
- The mission was to
do great fucking things
and serve sustainable seafood,
but literally it was
more about an experience,
offer an accessible
seafood restaurant, right?
A seafood restaurant that you
could walk in in a fuckin'
pair of sneakers and
jeans and spend 25 bucks.
It didn't exist in New York
for really great fresh fish,
and then also just do
some great shit out there.
And you know save the fuckin'
world while you're at it.
But I did that without partners,
and I mean I opened the
doors, it was fuckin' bananas.
It was like, I could not believe it.
I surpassed my projections
by like one two, you know?
And that's big for a small restaurant.
You know what I mean?
And you know, and dude,
fucking partnership is just a hard thing,
know what I'm saying?
- No shit.
- And it's such a tough
subject to talk about,
because I appreciate love and care about
all the partners that I have and had,
but like I have learned
an invaluable lesson
going into my next venture, which is--
- Dictatorships are awesome.
(Michael laughs)
Yo if you're creative,
dictatorships are awesome.
There are no two cooks in the kitchen.
- [Michael] It's really hard.
- No no, it doesn't exist.
It may sustain for a few seconds.
The only reason I've had
successful partnerships,
and family gets fuckin' crazy as fuck,
because I don't value money.
Otherwise they would've
been fucked up real good.
- And that's the truth too.
And then I think what
gets me into trouble with
the money guys is because
I'm not in it for the money.
If I was in it for the money--
- Right so an investor's like, yo,
why don't you maximize in returns?
You're like, yo.
- [Michael] I'm like because
this person's fucking dope.
- And we gotta wait, we gotta wait.
That's the answer.
- It takes time.
- This person's dope,
and we gotta wait for that to materialize
so we're covering more
overhead than we need to
to make the most efficient
short term EBIDA motherfucker.
- Yeah and I also think that like
if you are not focused
on the fucking people
you put in place to go out there,
like the ops guys will fuckin'
beat the marketing guy down,
like beat 'em down and be like,
why are you fuckin'
spending money on that,
you can't fuckin' spend money on that.
And the creative guys,
you can't spend money,
we can't spend money on that!
We can't fuckin' spend
money on a crew to come in
and create content and
put out some dope shit.
Like we need to fuckin' save on our cogs.
And I'm like, yo my man, like,
you've got nothing to operate
without marketing and innovation.
- That's why I'm the operator
and the marketing guy,
'cause this way I don't have to hear
anything about anything about anything.
I'm being dead fuckin' serious, man.
Of course you're so right,
it's why most people lose.
And to your point once you
get that right upfront,
then if you really stabilize that,
then you can milk brand in perpetuity.
And let people operate the edges.
- I care too much man, I care too much.
I think that that is--
- That's the best thing
that's happening to you.
The key is now to always like understand,
it's just self awareness now.
Which the evolution you're going
through, I'm going through.
Like dude I'm freaking out currently
that I'm like not sure
I like money at all.
Like it's been one thing that
I've sustained it to like do,
but I'm like, for the
first time in my life,
I don't know if I'm about this shit.
I don't know if I'm gonna be in a place,
yeah.
- Whoa.
- We're I'm like I just don't like money.
I'm almost starting to get,
I'm about to do some
weird shit, I can feel it.
Or I'm about to make a fuck load of money.
(Michael laughs)
Like one of the two things
is definitely about to happen.
- Or about to buy the Jets next year.
- Tomorrow, Jets.
It really is interesting though.
Like I'm goin' backwards.
Like baseball cards, you know like wine.
- So I have never met
in my life another man
who loves fucking garage saleing.
Like I had to put my garage saleing
game on the back burner.
- [Gary] Like you just didn't
even want people to know?
- No no no, I'm down for people to know.
My wife despises garage saleing, despises.
- [Gary] I'm aware of that concept.
- We brought a crib upstate, dude.
I'm like, there's a garage
sale every fucking three,
and so like we'd be riding--
- You couldn't get one
bullshit room out of that deal?
- Dude, listen, I--
- [Gary] (laughing) Listen, I understand.
- And so like when you're
running that hustle
and like having fun with
it, like I am a hunter.
- What is the single
best garage sale find?
Like when I say that,
what did you find that like was insane?
- I'm gonna share something
with you which is crazy town.
So this is like not a garage sale thing,
but this is some shit.
So like I built all the meatball shops,
I designed all the meatball
shops, I did all that shit.
And I did it all through garage saleing
and antique shop saleing.
I would go to like Brimfield right
which is happening right now.
I would go there and I would spend
18 hours to the head five days straight,
headphones on just like,
opening up fuckin' all the boxes that
people don't open up and finding shit,
you know what I'm saying?
I'm just like a maniac
when it comes down to that,
that garage saleing shit,
and it probably comes from
my father, 'cause he was too.
There's a house around the corner from me.
- By the way,
as a starting point to where
you're going with this,
I'm already fired the fuck up!
Just like I love my fuckin' parents but,
when you're talking garage sale talk,
if you start a sentence
with there's a house,
oh, man, go ahead.
- So listen, so listen,
so there's a house around
the corner from me,
abandoned but massive, listen.
And it's one house row.
- Real quick just for
everybody who's listening.
An abandoned house story
in garage sale talk
is like literally investing in Uber.
Go ahead.
(Michael laughs)
Literally, go ahead.
- And it's like right around the
corner from my house upstate.
One house row, no other houses.
I'm not even gonna say the name.
And I'd run by and I look at and I'm like,
oh my god, this is thing is
so brolic and big I'm like.
- You're like, there's shit in there.
- It took me a year to convince
myself to just say fuck it,
I'm going, I'm going.
- And break in the house.
Yeah, you had to.
- So my boy. (laughs)
- This is the best, I'm
so fired up right now.
By the way this is one of
the scenes in the film.
Go ahead, go ahead.
- We roll up in a pickup truck,
not like awesome like we're
gonna roll out with mad shit.
- Yeah yeah, just in case.
It was a just in case pickup truck.
I know what you're doing, I get it!
- So we roll up and we break in.
- [Gary] It's not like Home Alone,
it's more like just in case.
(Michael laughs)
Go ahead.
- Big house, like big house.
And we walk in and the
two of us are just like.
It was filled.
I'm telling you like
filled from the front--
- Right you didn't know if there was
gonna be a completely
empty house with nothing.
- I didn't know if I was walking into
the Tales from the fucking Crypt,
or if I was walking into like
holy shit you just hit the lottery.
- You had to go in, that's all you knew.
- I just had to walk into this place.
I didn't know if I was
gonna die or walk away
with some fuckin' ill baseball cards.
- So go ahead.
And it's super abandoned?
- 100% abandoned.
- Like straight up?
- Straight up abandoned.
Like nobody fuckin' is there, period.
- [Gary] For a long long time?
- I don't know for how long.
(Gary laughs)
But since I was there.
- They moved out last week!
Punchline of the story is the
family moved out the day before.
- Anyway, we go in there and it's filled.
There's just mad rooms everywhere,
and they're filled from
the floor to the ceiling,
just antiques, just piled
on top of each other.
Just everywhere.
I'm like, this is impossible.
This is like totally unrealistic.
And my boy is an antiques dealer,
and I think he shit his pants
the minute we walked in.
Literally I was like, bro.
Like it was insane.
And there was rooms filled
with books, floor to ceiling,
just books, stacks of books,
stacks of books, stacks of books.
I did one bad thing. (laughs)
- [Gary] You had to.
- I did one bad thing.
I grabbed a book.
That's the only thing I
took, word to my mother,
that was like the only thing I took.
- [Gary] That's not too bad.
- I took one book.
Earnest Hemingway, Man in the Sea.
Saw it, I was like, I'm taking that book,
you know what I mean?
Like I'm not a big reader
but like that's a fuckin'--
- You gotta give a head nod to
New York 15 year old once in a while.
- First edition.
I looked on eBay as soon
as I got back. (laughs)
- You're a much better man than me.
I would've sat there with my
phone looking up everything.
I would still be there right now.
- So the crazy thing is there was one room
that we just couldn't get into,
and we were like, this
must be the fuckin'.
(laughter)
- You broke in?
- [Michael] Trust me, we tried.
- Couldn't get in?
I'm gonna burn that fuckin' place down.
- We walked into the back of
the property and we looked up
and there were stacked Louis
Vuitton trunks in that room.
Like vintage Louis Vuitton
trunks in that room.
Anyway, you know what I mean, it was nuts.
Like we looked in the window,
we saw the LV on like the brown leather
in like those trunks and we were like,
holy shit, they got the stash,
they got the whole thing!
(Gary laughs)
They got it all!
Anyway so that's probably the craziest,
but like, I found so much shit, dude.
I've found so much shit.
I didn't even know that
that was your thing,
and then the minute you said garage sale,
I was like, oh my god,
I gotta meet this dude.
I was like there's no one else outside of
my weird antique dealer friend--
- D'oyu know what the best part for me is?
Is taking something I'm
genuinely passionate about,
knowing there's taboo-ness around it
or just not a huge culture around it
and then pushing it so hard that it--
- [Michael] You're doing it!
You're doing it, with the baseball cards.
- Bro I'm walking around garage sales,
the coolest motherfuckers,
23 year old you is out
there now like getting it,
and like giving me head nods.
- How many Ken Griffey upper deck first--
- '89 upper deck Ken
Griffey cards that I have?
- [Michael] Do you have now?
- None.
So I'm funny with my collection.
I kind of don't have one.
Like I'm in it for the process.
Got it?
The game, the hunt.
- I'm surprised you
don't love fishing, dude.
- You know what's funny,
it's funny you said that.
I don't love it, but I
kind of weirdly like it.
Like I kind of weirdly like it.
Like every time I do it,
once or three times a year,
I'm fairly in it.
- 'Cause the game of garage saleing
is going out there and like
seeing what you can find.
- I genuinely genuinely
also like selling things.
So like if I could grab
a fish out of the sea
and then sell it to Troudy for five bucks?
I'd probably like it
so much more. (laughs)
- So you're not only in it for the hunt,
you're in it for the actual sale as well.
- But not for the money from the sale.
- Just seeing what you can get.
- Do you understand?
The curiosity, which is why--
- [Michael] We didn't
take one question, FYI.
(Michael laughs)
- Right, sorry everyone!
Because bro, you know why?
Especially if something has no value
the challenge of creating value?
Like I might start actually
selling things in nature.
Like I've been thinking about this lately.
This is really weird.
- [Michael] Like going mushroom
foraging and selling them?
- No, 'cause that has value.
I'm thinking about starting a store
that is just random
things I find in the wild.
- Like a leaf?
- Like a leaf.
(Michael laughs)
- That might be the craziest
thing you've ever said.
Like you say crazy shit,
but that could might very well
be the most off the chart.
- You know what is unbelievable
about that, Michael?
Is that I'm confident that
it would do extremely well.
That if I created a brand that the store
was selling one off things in nature.
- [Michael] Like framed leaf?
- Nope.
- Just leaf?
- Leaf, rock, rock with weird imprint.
Like straight up like pseudo fossil shit,
or just like can from 43rd Street.
I just have this weird
feeling that somebody
can build a crazy brand and Shopify,
like think about this, you see where I'm--
- I gotta say something dude,
I gotta tell you the most
fucking insane story of all time.
This guy, this was like as real as it got.
I remember back in the
day when Astor Place--
- Yes.
- So back in the day
when Astor Place was
actually Astor Place, right?
There was a guy that would set up shop.
- By the way my number one
favorite thing about New York
by far is that a 38 year
old can sit here in 2019
and be like when Astor Place
was fuckin' Astor Place.
Meanwhile if we did some
library shit right now,
in 1986 in the New York
Post some guy's like,
when Astor Place was
Astor Place, and in 1971.
That is my favorite thing about New York.
- So good.
Like I wonder if it's still
actually happens, right?
Like I don't know.
- We're getting so soft bro that in 2057
somebody's gonna be like
in 2019 in New York,
like it was crazy, like
people weren't hugging you.
- Dude there was a guy, listen,
there was a guy who used to
set up shop on the street,
and he had a sign that said I'm
about to sell you some shit.
Word, he had jars of shit.
(laughter)
- [Gary] And people bought?
- I don't fucking know.
But this guy was like, I remember
it, I was like, this guy!
- Bro, I might actually do this.
Like I'm thinking about this.
I might start a brand called like Earth
spelled like in a weird
way and it's a Shopify,
and I'm just gonna pick up random
shit on Earth and price it,
write some badass copy about it,
make a little micro video
and do a million a year.
- You will.
- Of course I will.
But I'm gonna do it pseudo
incognito and nobody,
well now the concept's out, fuck!
- [Michael] Blew it.
- I am so obsessed to
doing something in my life
that nobody knows that
has anything to do with me
to eliminate all excuses that
I used my platform to do it
and just blow everybody's
fuckin' mind and just be like,
that was me, like six years later.
- I like that idea.
- [Gary] Isn't that clever?
- Yeah it is.
- Why is the New York
night scene so fucked
besides the answer everyone gives
which is money took over and any dork can
buy a fuckin' table 'cause rents got high?
- I mean I went to the
tunnel in the limelight
when I was young young
young, and I worked at Life,
that was the night club that
I worked at when I was young.
I don't go to clubs anymore,
I haven't gone out in so long.
Years and years.
So I'm like the wrong guy,
because I don't know how bad it is,
but I can only imagine it's pretty bad.
- It's not that it's bad.
It's that nobody here can speak to
the desperation of going
somewhere this Saturday night.
That has been eliminated from
the youth lexicon in New York.
- I think in New York at that time
the celebrity scene was a
little bit (sighs) grittier.
And the celebrity scene drove it.
The first thing that I ever wanted to do
in the night life was go to Sky,
Sky Bar, you remember that place?
So that was like the first
thing I wanted to do.
I wanted to go see fuckin',
I wanted to see like Leonardo DiCaprio.
- And who he was with.
- And like what they were
smoking, you know what I'm saying?
And Kate Moss.
And they were just like out
there, you know what I mean?
And like who knows,
I don't know what that celebrity
clique is like right now.
- [Gary] Plus everyone's a celebrity.
- Yeah I guess so.
You know what it is maybe?
Ah.
I mean this is a theory,
it could be wrong.
- [Gary] It's a hypothesis.
- It's just not exclusive anymore.
There's zero exclusivity,
everything is tracked and
traced and documented.
- And edited.
And also leads to different behavior
when you know that you're being filmed.
- There is no uncertainty when
you walk into the VIP room.
- [Gary] How different is metal right now?
- [John] Versus what?
- 1987.
Same shit?
- [John] I think it's
definitely a little bit softer.
- Yeah, everything has
to be softer, right?
Like that's just the punch line.
That's good in some ways, and not.
- You know it's the same thing like
you know the hip hop game is
definitely different dude,
it's just definitely different.
Like I grew up listening to
Naz and Wu Tang and Mob Deep
and you know Black Moon
and like that shit.
- Black Moon.
- How good is Black Moon?
Probably one of the
best albums of all time,
like I think so.
My hip hop interests,
like when I work out,
I listen to all the new shit.
But like when I'm at home
listening to hip hop,
my interests stopped after like '96.
- That's what happens.
It's the same reason there
are some 70 year olds
only listening to fuckin'
The Rolling Stones.
Like that's the game.
- I don't know man, I think that there's--
- [Gary] I promise you that's the game.
- You think?
- It's old man talk.
- But listen dude.
The sound changed, drastically.
- Everything changes.
Do you know what a restaurateur from 1947
thinks about a meatball place?
- [Michael] I wonder. (chuckles)
- Let's leave it at that,
let's leave it at that.
Bro, thank you so much,
this was one of my favorite episodes bro.
- [Michael] Good times.
- Usually I say you keep asking questions,
we'll keep answering them.
You keep watching, we'll keep hanging out.
See ya! (laughs)
That was amazing.